what's the deal with airplane peanuts
here we go let's get a little this is
the first person wearing a shirt i
believe
that's our audience all right hey bill
hey theo this is marissa from raleigh
north carolina
and uh so bill i heard you say on i
believe it was joe rogan's podcast
that you really like the film once upon
a time in hollywood and you've seen it
several times
and i know theo said that he walked out
halfway through it
um so i was just wondering maybe if you
could talk about why you loved it so
much and theo
why you walked out halfway through it
anyway gang gang
well this is where bill and i don't talk
anymore after this no no i if you didn't
like it he didn't like it i absolutely
[ __ ] loved it i heard on your podcast
you say that you loved it oh my god
dude it's the best work uh leo's i mean
brad pitt's great first time he watched
it
i was just like i want to be like brad
pitt's the guy i want to be yeah and
then the second time i watched it was
like oh my god i'm just like leo's
character
i have an emotional [ __ ] mess well i
don't know what part you walked out in
i walked out after they went to that
house for the first time after they met
the old guy
and they were in the yard and then his
car was had a flat tire
and at that point i was like i got to
get out of here i don't know what these
guys are doing you know i felt like it
was just kind of a waste of
i don't know it just i couldn't get into
it and i didn't know what was going on
and it made me feel uncomfortable it's
like i got to get out of here because i
started to feel like
everybody knows what's going on and i
don't know what's going on you know i
guess
yeah that's that's for you and the
therapist buddy yeah if that happens to
you at the [ __ ] movies if you think
the whole movie
the whole movie theater gives a [ __ ]
about whether
no i don't think you're making are you
making like audible noises that you do
oh
whoa oh oh my god that's the only way
they would know
[ __ ] man i don't know i was so [ __ ] up
mandy yeah you do
yeah you do i really did it you do under
the insider trackman you do
i really didn't though i really did it
man yeah
i'm i'm not gonna sit here and try to
talk you into that masterpiece it's one
of my
it might be my favorite thing that's
what you said that's unbelievable colin
calls you billy
but i [ __ ] bill i'm just immediately
noticing i don't know about the chain if
it's
if it's thick enough to be that warm
that level of confidence
yeah what's more of a necklace
when the chain's out yes he has on a fat
chick ankle bracelet around his [ __ ]
neck
no i say guy when the chain's out yeah
when it changes up yeah but he does make
a good point it's not really a chain
it's more of an ankle bracelet out of
big well yeah my kid's mom was like why
are you wearing women's jewelry yeah i
was like shut up well here's the thing
his mom bought him for that and he
uh like high school and then he found it
in his room and he put it back on
i'm saying his face it's too much guido
when it comes out no you know what it is
you've you've
aged past that chain where it becomes a
necklace
if you're like 18 i get it this is his
first one your
bought it for him yeah one time uh i was
in
uh rome right
one day with my wife and went to the
vatican to go take the tour
of the sistine chapel yeah so there's a
way to
i don't know we went through the whole
[ __ ] thing and we're just sitting
there we come in and we're looking at it
whatever and we're standing in the line
it took for [ __ ] ever so i say to my
wife i was going you know
if i lived here i'd open a bar across
the street called the 17th chapter
she goes what i got 17 chapel she goes
what i don't know
6 16 chapel 17 chapel it's like having
the 19th hole
oh my god but i think she just she
looked at me
oh my like oh my god i'm breeding with
this [ __ ]
and then all i can say i did all i could
say was this i just go
no it isn't and then and it was funny
then i walked in i walked in and i
looked up and i didn't even like it
it's not even that big it's like it's
like the size of the side of this
[ __ ] thing
he melted it should have taken way less
time i'm telling you they're paying them
by the [ __ ] hour
no i have a lot of those i have a lot
oh jesus don't die on us man though i
can imagine
you're the room before it you're like 15
and 16
i was always this that was the 16th
chapel no i'm bald
no no but you're going bald i know but
did you because you still had some
residue of air residue yeah yeah you had
residue you know
you could have done that noble thing
that you were doing but
yeah but you didn't you just understand
it yeah it's one of those things
where are we going right now no we don't
there's no there's no rules but
okay i'm just asking you a question okay
right i'm gonna answer it i
i understand that but why are you your
head looks like
you know um darth vader when he took his
[ __ ] helmet off wasn't
remember that when he was just all
[ __ ] up yeah yeah
yeah what is that is that the
that's fine you're bill burr but i i'm
trying to answer your question yeah go
ahead i just process you coming out of
the gate [ __ ] on me
um yeah you know when you start to lose
your hair you you got
three options yeah
you can yeah and there's subsets to all
of them all right
okay you can do the rogaine the hair
plugs
uh they glue some [ __ ] on your head they
take some some of your pube hair and you
get an afro
yeah or you can uh
just sort of let it happen which you
were doing which i was like that's
the dope way to do it oh i'm glad i'm
glad i had your approval
or you can just say [ __ ] it
yeah and do what i did so i just said
[ __ ] it okay and
and and i do i love how you came at me
aggressive and now you're going you got
your
little panda hands i love how you attack
my little pound hand huh that's what you
look like you look like a little panda i
know i was just
because when you took your shirt like a
little adolescent bear
[Laughter]
you know i was 19. i was freshman
sophomore so i was actually like an
idiot
also doing a couple of cycles of
winstrol yeah i was on windshield at the
time yeah he did a couple cycles what
are you gonna do
yeah so little steroids so thank you
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yes steroids for
basketball yeah just you could move
i mean i could just you know i could
like tomahawk dunk i i was just like
being an athlete basketball was such a
huge part of my life that my friends
you know when i do comedy if they you
know do something with comedy my friends
from wait you couldn't dunk and then you
took roids and then you could no i
always could i always could
well i couldn't always i started being
able to dunk when i was like 16.
i did winstro once for like six weeks so
it was a small part of it
you did a cycle i did a cycle just one
cycle yeah
happens and to be honest with you when i
did that cycle i was my junior year in
college it was my worst year because i
was dealing with a lot of anxiety
and all [ __ ] from your balls
all that he could go between the legs a
little easier that year yeah
the anxiety but i um
it was just the way to communicate i
remember you felt it division three i
gotta get on roids i need i need a
competitive edge here yeah
we got to beat lasalle academy next week
you know what fascinates me is like
basically the first 16 or 17 years of my
life
when i never i mean i took a couple sips
of my you know stole a beer here there
for my dad but i never really went out
and tried to get drunk until i was like
16 or 17.
but i went for like a decade and a half
like i was straight edge
you know what i mean and but the thing
was oh you told kid you were straight
edge you're like i don't know no no
no just thought of being a kid it's not
like your first 10 years of your life
you're like [ __ ] playground man i need a
drink
that's just not where your world is at
and the thing was it's pandora's box
then once you catch a buzz
then it's just like oh man this is this
other kind of living
and it's it's you know i i yeah i didn't
understand that i was kind of using that
as like a uh
i'm not saying i'm never gonna [ __ ]
drink again but i just i i had i had to
like
i kind of just had to like step back and
just be like all right because you know
the reality is i got a kid so i just
didn't want to be that i'm like
you don't get drunk when your kids
around my [ __ ] lou grant with a
bottle of whiskey in the remember that
mary tyler moore show
she'd have a rough day and she'd come in
and i don't remember the whole show i
can explain it to you yeah
if i can explain it like a guy just i
don't know what that is all right
i don't know i don't know and the second
i started to explain like i don't know
the whole show all right
i get it i get it i believe it's that
comic add like i i don't even [ __ ]
i'm not into it i don't want to hear it
i got it your show go ahead continue
i remember uh all right let's talk about
old shows then we don't have to i just
was it was so funny how you [ __ ] you
bailed twice on that you mean patty duke
made me feel like an [ __ ] like that
was the 15th time i [ __ ] brought it
up
sorry no mary tyler moore one of the
great ensemble [ __ ] cast of all time
i do know she just died recently uh yeah
i mean i was gonna bring up a more
positive story about the show
but yeah it's the second time i bring up
[ __ ] george michael those are an aids
event
huh some sort of gay thing well i didn't
say gay bro
but why would you say aids because he
had aids man no he didn't
did he i jesus no he didn't well people
have been saying he did
i think you are confusing it with gay no
i'm not i didn't know he was gay i knew
that apparently got aids in a park
that's what i heard
and now he blew a guy in a porta potty
and got busted for lewd activity
and then you know he you know had a
little [ __ ] you know he liked getting
a little buzz at the end of the [ __ ]
day and maybe he got away from i think
that's what happened but like what i
would like to focus on was how amazing
his voice was
and how talented he was and i played
this performed and stood in the same
spot that this guy did yeah that's what
the point was not what he died of
yeah oh wait a minute and it was what
happened in your life
who'd you lose early on you're really
into death well no
i mean i remember listening you don't
want to get to know mary tyler or more
because you're afraid she's
gonna leave you too
[Laughter]
i remember listening to uh george
michael on the school bus when i would
go to school
and i felt like and i would always sit
by myself do you feel like you were
gonna catch aids
by doing that some sort of airborne hiv
through the [ __ ] radio
i mean bro i was holding it up to my ear
you know
i couldn't feel my ass in a ruthless
school bus one of the the wind born
radio aids was gonna get me
[Music]
like it's a a place